es ist einer der seltenen sonnentage in
diesem sommer ein guter tag zum fischen
erst recht wenn man das meer liebt sowie
andreas nitsche guard 20 jahre war er
berufsfischer jetzt ist der kabeljau
frank nur noch ein hobby
denn der fisch machte sich rar
es ist nicht das geld für das andreas
rausfährt dafür ist der fang zu spärlich
es ist leidenschaft dieses leben mit der
natur und dazu gehört für ihn auch der
walfang
es ist etwas besonderes
du siehst hier vögel und dort sind auch
die wale
auch wenn man sie jetzt nicht zieht die
tiere leben frei und wir nehmen sie aus
dem wasser und essen
sie werden nicht gezüchtet wie sonst wo
in europa die schweine hühner oder kühe
nur um dann geschlachtet zu werden hier
passt die natur darauf auf und wir
bedienen uns während er erzählt taucht
ein schiff auf dass die fehringer
bestens kennen
es ist depressiv war der organisation
sea shepherd
die aktivisten wollen das schlachten der
wale verhindern
sie halten diese tradition für überholt
für überflüssig auch wenn diese grint
wahlen nicht vom aussterben bedroht sind
wir haben nichts gegen die bewohner
wir sind aber gegen das töten der
meeressäuger das müssten sie nicht mehr
machen weil sie das fleisch nicht mehr
benötigen
die fehringer sagen aber immer wieder
sie töten die tiere um etwas zu essen zu
haben
es sind diese bilder die tierschützer
rund um den globus zu wütend machen
das meerwasser ist blutgetränkt am
strand liegen die toten wale die
bewohner des kleinen dorfes fahrer sind
haben sie mit ihren boten an den strand
getrieben und dort getötet
wenn sie ein stück fleisch auf dem
teller haben wollen muss dafür ein tier
sterben
ob das hinter verschlossenen türen oder
wie hier in diesem öffentlichen
schlachthaus geschieht macht keinen
unterschied
doch dieses schlachthaus ist bestens
bewacht die dänische marine schickte
extra eine fregatte und schlauchboote
der polizei sollen zudem die
tierschützer von sea shepherd auf
distanz halten
mit erfolg selbst als die tiere auf die
mole gehievt werden drängt die polizei
eine kleine gruppe aktivisten und andere
zuschauer zurück die meisten polizisten
kommen als verstärkung eigens aus
dänemark für sea shepherd wird die
arbeit schwieriger sea shepherd hatte es
im vergangenen jahr geschafft den
walfang zu stören und sogar wahlgruppen
zu vertreiben
so konnten die insulaner sie nicht
fangen oder gar töten
deshalb wird sich die regierung hier
gedanken gemacht haben was sie
unternehmen kann um sie schätze zu
stoppen
mit gesetz und polizei
diesmal haben sie es geschafft nach ein
paar stunden kommt der leiter der
waljagd mit listen zurück darauf steht
wie viel fleisch jeder von dem wal
bekommt auch andreas nitsche tat steht
ein anteil zu
er und seine nachbarn machen sich an die
arbeit
sie lösen die fettschicht ab um an das
begehrte fleisch zu kommen
der wahl wird fast vollständig verwertet
zwei stunden lang herrscht hochbetrieb
auf dem kai und andreas frau freut sich
es ist einfach eine gute gelegenheit die
steuern hier sind hoch und ich verdiene
auch nicht zu viel
so ist es eine gute möglichkeit mal
etwas anderes auf den tisch zu bekommen
den verringern ist es wichtig die eigene
kultur zu bewahren
sie schadeten damit schließlich keinem
wenn wir aufhören wale zu töten aber
weiter die ozeane verschmutzen dann
sterben die tiere an krebs oder an einer
anderen krankheit
deshalb sollten wir eher damit aufhören
die natur zu verschmutzen
rund 800 grint wale erlegen die
fehringer im schnitt jedes jahr zum
eigenen verzehr
sie werden daran festhalten auch wenn
sie dafür weltweit kritik ernten